fait la queue aujourd'hui à cause d'un
grâce à l'interview vous avez donné à
hugo clément / combiné news où vous
dites donc avoir été harcelés et menacés
c'est vrai que nous ici dans l'équipe ça
nous a vraiment touché récemment
notamment l'équipe rédactionnelle mais
aussi l'équipe des chroniqueurs vous
êtes victime de harcèlement sur les
réseaux et sur les réseaux c'est dans la
rue aussi c'est sam sur les réseaux
c'est vrai que c'est sans cesse et
expliquez nous ce qui se passe en fait
en fait je dénonce donc l'harcèlement
depuis très longtemps
ouais bien avant balanced ont peur etc
je dénonce le fait d'être harcelée sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est une chose mais
dans la rue c'est ça je vais passer mes
courses je vais faire mes courses on
insulte de tous les noms mais qu'est ce
qu'on vous dit pourquoi parce que vous
êtes une ancienne actrice porno parce
que vous êtes une équipe en eau donc
vous insulte on vous dit quoi ça va
passer que le csa ou dont vous inquiétez
pas non mais on n'est pas dans une jarre
souvenir c'était cinq mecs dans une
voiture je faisais mes courses et un
après midi et mon petit casier
tranquillement et là j'entends une
équipe est en recul mais tellement fort
que tout le monde entend tout le monde
entend ça se passe quand chèque avec mon
compagnon bien su voir s'effacer
beaulieu mais ça va reste très très fort
et me soutient totalement dans fameux
soutient toujours
voilà après à l'harcèlement sur les
réseaux sociaux qui est ultra ultra vion
c'est en cela qu'on y aller plus vous
allez encore sur les réseaux sociaux par
givet dans le sens où si demain je me
déconnecte de tout sans que ce soit un
choix personnel mais si je me déconnecte
à cause de ça ça voudra dire que les
gens gagnent et pour moi ce serait
serait une soumission en fait d'accord
je peux pas que vous l'affrontez voilà
ce qui se dit vous et et vous voulez
vous voilà ce qu'il vous aussi vous
voulez pas vous dit de dire voilà je
quittais réseaux sociaux parce que ça
serait jamais gagné le main les linges
et mais il ya un quartier qui est un peu
compliqué on diana va pas dans ce
quartier est un peu chaud donc elle va
pas y aller à cause de ça ça peut
paraître bête parce que c'est que des
réseaux sociaux mais pour moi c'est un
sens dans le jeu n'est pas à me retirer
à cause de leurs deux personnes
les menaces qui harcèlent dans
l'interview d'hugo clément le moment le
plus poignant c'est aussi le moment où
vous dites ne pas vouloir faire d'enfant
parce que vous avez peur pour pour votre
enfant et qui qu'ils soient victimes de
2,2 de voile a fait une victime
collatérale de ce qui vous arrive pas on
attend vous inquiétez pas pour l'antenne
quand on veut il n'y a pas il ya pascal
soyez tous là
après c'est tout faire un enfant
c'était mon seul rêve dans ma vie
c'était celui là j'avais je rêve pas
d'avoir d'argent je rêve pas de gloire
je m'en fous tout ça moi c'était voilà
faire un enfant et inculquer de
merveilleuses valeur de lui donner
tellement d'amour que je fais qui
l'auraient manqué de rien de pro avoir
renoncé pour avoir renoncé à 28 ans vous
avez le temps oui il faut lier franches
à ce que si ça tenait qu'à moi j'en
frein il comprendrait au moment venu et
je m'expliquerai avec son père bien sûr
mais voilà maman elle a un passé ça
empêche pas de maman et elle même maman
elle a une morale mais au vu de moi
comment je je je suis détruite par les
réseaux sociaux
clara morgane quand elle a annoncé sa
grossesse c'est eh oui bon ben on va
pouvoir lui dire fils de [ __ ] ça va être
tout le temps tout temps comme ça il ya
sur les sur les réseaux il ya aussi à
l'école il faut il faut passer au delà
de ça vous viviez venez vous viviez pas
à travers les raisonnements envie d'être
maman je lui faut que je joue les mamans
que mon enfant
il est des séquelles je ne je me
l'interdis je veux pas je veux pas
qu'ils souffrent si toi après on n'a pas
besoin de faire du duo pour faire
déranger ça mais je sais les dot
d'autres parents qui ne font pas ce que
vous avez fait les oui sont des gamins
il les maltraite donc mais ça c'est des
parents d'un enfant quoi moi je suis sûr
que vous allez changer d'avis je pense
que vous devriez changer d'avis sous
tension monte à des choix de vie vous
n'avez 28 ans et je suis persuadé que
voilà que vous allez avoir un enfant un
jour et qui sera très heureux à vos
côtés ça j'en suis sûr et saint-pierre
15 ans après je ne la veut redresser
voilà
parmi les questions clés chine avait
bien une question se sent mieux celle de
valérie non non c'est pas ça cet ami
l'avait bien mérité non elle contient
tout le monde
oui j'ai contacté les parents justement
qui vous a demandé
ouais allez y ont posé la question cette
gamme passage de votre interview que je
trouve formidable c'est vous pas entre
autres vous parlez des enfants et des
enfants mineurs en disant je souhaite
recontacter l'entente pour leur dire
faites attention quand même à ce que
regardent votre enfant il est est ce
qu'il est en âge de regarder ça vraiment
fait attention à ce que vous le savez
non mais ça c est ce que vous
conseilleriez à des jeunes filles ou des
jeunes hommes de faire des films pour
des films pornos pas du tout
cette différence de traitement entre les
hommes et les femmes
sexiste même tendance mignon c'est que
les hornets et des bons coups c'est
visionner les fils et des traînées ça
même si fredy était considéré comme un
dieu
c'est ça exactement c'est fou donc pour
les jeunes filles il ya aussi beaucoup
d'acteurs pour nous qui ont très mal
fini et malheureusement il ya eu
beaucoup de soucis dans ce milieu là
faut pas occulter sa part contre juste
une chose concernant tout ce qui est
suicidé que c'est faux bien comprendre
une chose c'est pas le porte en lui-même
qui détruit les actrices ou les acteurs
ce n'est pas le porno il ya des ja défi
qu'est le jardin d'autres moins bien
lors ces cas là tu vas voir une
psychothérapeute penser mais voilà c'est
comme le
enfin vous il ya les moments voilà en
germe j'aurai un petit peu moins bien
mais c'est pas le quitter non c'est moi
c'est le sait ça vous êtes en train de
dire qu'il m'a détruit c'est important
de le répéter que ce n'est pas le truc
des filles c'est la société c'est ça
c'est cet achat grognards des autres
c'est le regard des autres le fait qu'on
peut même pas se reconvertir alors qu'on
n'a rien commis d'illégal
non mais c'est pas des meurtriers à un
quelqu'un qui arrêtent ya purgé 20 ans
de prison
demain il peut se reconvertir mais vous
il ya toujours cette vous êtes toujours
marqué comme vous avez parlé clara
morgane
voilà qui est très heureuse a maintenant
clara voilà mais c'est vrai que voilà
c'est une hypocrisie totale parce que
malheureusement ceux qui regardent pas
de film x
il vous connaissent pas voilà donc ce
qui vous insulte c'est ceux qui ont
regardé tout ça oui mais très courte
mais mais plus d'un point de vue
sociologique c est ce que je sais pas de
quand vous avez arrêté de faire du porno
deux ans les deux ans est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'aujourd'hui que ce
soit leur âge les réseaux ou dans la rue
s'il ya beaucoup plus de haine est
beaucoup plus insultes aujourd'hui
qu'ils pouvaient avoir avant oui on est
d'accord il y en a beaucoup plus et
d'ailleurs quand mathieu des fois
intervenu sur les réseaux sociaux fin la
violence moi je le comprends totalement
parce que à force de se faire taper
dessus tout temps tout le temps tout le
temps faim reste des êtres humains quoi
bien sûr si vous avez arrêté la compotée
de quoi il a peur nous a complètement
fait quoi maintenant
mais pas me dire je peux pas le dire
parce que c'est illégal et a eu des
problèmes dans bone of jour où je veux
me reconvertir fin vous aimeriez faire
quoi
je me suis vite la discrimination est en
fait je ferais éventuellement une à peu
près une future collègue de pascal
parrot sort saluer non c'est pas vrai
quoi comme vous êtes
c'est ça vous ne pas dire précisément
mai
n'ont pas d'enfant parce que ça créera
au scandale une ex actrice qui s'occupe
de golf sa créance grenelle met d'accord
vous êtes face à un 2 sur nrj12 qui va
arriver là non vous allez faire date et
les enquêteurs n'ont pas quoi non pas de
la télé dans le même très bien eh bien
écoutez ça vous plaît
totalement c'est vrai vous êtes heureuse
la nuit après ce qui est compliqué c'est
voilà là la discrimination qu'on subit
quotidiennement par exemple pour la
reconversion c'est moi c'est un métier
c'est un métier j'ai toutes les qualités
pour le faire et je suis très
travailleuse sans me dire tu te
réveilles à 5 heures du matin j'y suis
il n'y a pas d'arrêt maladie je suis
quelqu'un qui aime le 6ème travail voilà
donc par exemple un meetic pourrait pas
faire jean michel maire mais voilà on ne
subit la discrimination et ça faut que
ça change
il me semble que marlène chappuis a
d'ailleurs arrêts prévus sur combiné
exactement alors elle a réagi à la
réussit à cette interview et ben moi je
vais vous dire la seule chose que
j'espère que vous allez faire si vous
allez changer d'avis et vous allez
décider d'avoir un enfant parce que
votre compagnon vous serez une mère
formidable vous n'avait que 28 ans
est-ce que je vous faire un gros bisou
[Applaudissements]